failed and disgraced former fox news
host bill o'reilly
lost his mind
over minorities after the highland park
shooting on monday you have to see this
video clip let me set up what's going on
with bill o'reilly who by the way
seems even more unhinged than i remember
him when he was on his fox news show
the governor of illinois pritzker held a
press conference after the shooting
and
one of the things that bill o'reilly
took from that is
democrats and the left
only care about these types of shootings
because the perpetrators aren't
minorities but when you look at
gang violence drug crime violence etc
it's minorities and so democrats don't
want to talk talk about it now the funny
thing about this as we look at the clip
is in saying this bill o'reilly's
reasoning is completely flawed and i'll
tell you why in a moment but he's sort
of admitting the mass shooters are
almost exclusively young white men right
i mean he's basically saying the
demographics of the gang violence don't
interest democrats
by definition he's saying the
demographics of the mass shooters are
different and we know that they are it's
mostly young white men in the united
states okay so here's bill o'reilly
completely losing his mind saying
democrats don't want to deal with
shootings when it's minorities doing the
shooting o'reilly at his most disheveled
and unhinged you jb are not going to
stop loons and you won't stop
crime drug crime drug gangs because
they're minority gangs that's why you
won't stop them
you phony
you
aid in a bet this murder in chicago
every blanken day by the way again it
was not in chicago they love to do the
chicago thing because they they believe
chicago puts the image in your mind
again
of gang violence or whatever this was in
a swanky suburb
you don't be sanctimonious with me
so riley having a having a normal one
this is a real get off my lawn moment
and i've spoken about this so many times
preventing individual single shootings
when specific people are being targeted
like you see in gang violence is number
one most importantly completely
different animal
than what we're talking about with mass
shootings in terms of his causes and in
terms of solutions and prevention and
number two
it's it is really difficult to prevent
individual
violence
even in some cases when you eliminate
the guns although you do sort of
dissuade people you make them have to
maybe use a more personal tool like a
knife or whatever it doesn't mean we
don't try so let's just think it through
and again when we talk about deaths at
the hands of guns we have three
categories that we're concerned with and
these are no particular order you have
gun suicides
you have sort of individual gun
homicides which includes um disgruntled
uh of spouses it includes uh you know
hit men it includes gang violence drug
deals gone wrong that type of thing
and then you've got your mass shooters
these are three different things
the causes are different the potential
solutions are different it it's they're
just different things consider
if a disgruntled psychopathic ex-spouse
wants to kill his girlfriend and i say
his girlfriend or his ex-wife because
it's almost always a man doing it just
the way it is
the type of policy we're talking about
on mass shootings is mostly not going to
do that now if you make it really
difficult to even get a handgun
the x the disgruntled ex-spouse will say
well i'm going to do it with a knife or
i'm going to do it with a baseball bat
or whatever it's more it's more personal
and up close so they may not do it but
it is a different type of thing um when
it when a gang member member says i've
been disrespected by this person and
i've now gotta get get back at them
you know limiting rifles so that they
end up with a handgun or even in some
cases limiting hand they if they're
determined to go after a particular
individual they're going to do it to
some degree maybe they won't kill them
separately
here we're talking about mass shootings
where you need certain tools and certain
provisions to dissuade you make guns
harder to get or at least you make the
deadlier guns harder to get well then
this particular shooter might have
killed fewer people that would be good
we want zero people killed but killing
one instead of seven is better
injuring one instead of dozens is better
you make the ammunition really expensive
well maybe he wouldn't have had as many
bullets would have reduced the lethality
of it you put an age limit on rifles
well he might have been relegated to a
handgun
the number of people he'll kill with a
handgun from a rooftop is probably a low
lower number than what he was able to do
it's just different and so bill
o'reilly's saying you just don't want to
go after black people who commit crime
that's what o'reilly's saying
and it's absurd and these are different
types of of incidents and we should deal
with all of them
but the way you reduce gun violence has
components that are very different uh
when it comes to i'm sorry the way you
reduce gang gun violence has elements
that are very different than when we
talk about these typical mass shootings
and so we don't say one is a bigger or
smaller problem or whatever we say we
want to deal with multiple problems the
fact that treating
um
you know a damaged knee
is done differently than cancer
doesn't mean we ignore either it just
means we take different approaches
that's all that's all that we're saying
and o'reilly i mean look at this guy
completely out of his gourd completely
out of his court has lost it alright let
me know your thoughts find me on twitter
at dpakman we'll take a quick break and
be back with so much more
all of us have had the experience of
dropping out of an important zoom call
because of a flaky wi-fi connection i've
had it when live streaming if you can
think of something more humiliating let
me know uh something else i struggle
with is when i'm on the go
finding a good enough connection to
upload or download large video files
which i regularly need to do what if you
could fix all of this by using more than
one internet connection at the same time
like the coffee shop wifi
and your mobile phones connection
combining them into one super internet
connection that's faster and more
reliable our sponsor speedify is the
only app that can combine multiple
internet sources into one
fantastic
super connection like this this will
improve your live streaming your video
calling your gaming the web browsing
everything you do online use speedify on
all devices pc mac iphone android linux
works with any type of internet
connection simple to use runs in the
background i use it everywhere
especially when traveling and it works
great try speedify risk free
for seven days and get twenty percent
off go to speedify.com
pacman and use the code pacman click the
link down in the description